I am the only person who knew how much danger I was in
and nobody would believe me.
This is the wildest story of fucking abuse
and someone being let down by everyone around them.
Everyone around them and how she got through it.
It's the love story between birds poogake and Linda Riss.
They met in 1957.
While Bert was not a good looking man,
he was awkward and weird.
He was also 10 years older than her.
When he meets her,
he like instantly falls in love
cause she's the most beautiful thing he's ever seen.
He's just like going crazy.
She looks like Elizabeth Taylor.
Just. She's kind of annoyed with him.
Like literally they meet and he sends her a dozen roses to her house.
So he like comes on strong and hard real fast from the jump.
He was an attorney.
He was also like,
he helped produce movies or he had just been overseas in Europe.
The average income at that time was about $4,000 a year.
That was like what the average person made.
He was making about $80,000 a year back in the 50s.
So this dude was.
Had a lot of money.
He was an attorney,
he was powerful,
he had connections.
He owned a nightclub in the area where like,
Johnny Mathis and like, people of the time would go and perform
and he would walk in with her
and as soon as they walked into the club,
he made Sure. That the band always be.
The second you see me walking in with her,
you play this fucking old song. Linda,
her name. So every time she walked in, it was this huge grand entrance.
Like, talk about fucking love.
Bombing the fuck out of her.
Because financial security is literally
one of the most important reasons
a woman looks for a man
in those days.
She was, she fell for it.
She's like, alright, cool,
I'm down. The grandmother's like, you know what?
How the fuck is he single?
He's 10 years older than you.
How did somebody not snatch him up already?
This is. This isn't true.
He's like, yeah,
I knew that she found out, so I beat her to the chase.
I was like, yo, listen,
I'm married,
I want to get a divorce,
blah blah blah.
He's like playing her along,
literally future faking.
He's like, no, I'm gonna leave her,
I'm gonna leave her,
I wanna be with you,
blah blah blah.
Linda's like a pretty stand up woman.
She's like, I don't wanna do it.
I don't wanna be with somebody who hasn't. Wife,
when you get a divorce,
hit me up and I'm gonna.
I'm gonna do me.
The next day he's like, look,
I got the papers.
Her not being an idiot,
she writes down the fucking divorce number that he gives her.
But looking at it,
I mean, it looks like real paper.
So she's like, I mean, you Are an attorney.
Like, I've seen you do big,
powerful things.
Maybe it's possible the back of her mind,
she knew she could get that shit checked out.
Weeks go by and she's still dating him.
She's falling in love.
She's like, wow,
this is amazing.
Like, okay,
he really did get the divorce.
He did it. Like,
okay. Like,
this is awesome.
She's. She's falling for it.
No, he's still fucking married.
She's like a fucking done.
I'm done with you.
I'm done, done, done, done, done.
She goes, has a hot girl, summer.
She finds a new man,
and her and Larry get engaged.
And she's gonna be happy and everybody's happy.
And she's in love, and he's in love,
and this is great.
And she has a big,
beautiful engagement party.
And the morning after her engagement party,
the doorbell rings.
She's getting ready for work.
Her mommy answers and says, oh,
somebody's at the door with a gift for you.
It's. It was an engagement party gift.
So they call her to the door,
she's still getting ready for work,
tying her hair up in a bow.
And she walks up to the door like, yeah,
but, you know, so excited.
And the guy throws lie in her eyes.
But literally,
even as she's healing in the hospital,
Burt is like, I'm so sorry.
Cause he was the one who paid to have this attack done to her.
He decided like,
well, if I can't have Her,
nobody will. I don't know what the goal was,
but he went to her dad asking for his help to get Linda to be with him.
And the dad was like,
well, you're too late, cause she already started engaged to that guy.
We at the party yesterday,
she could see the red flags.
She even says,
I am the only person who knew how much danger I was in,
and nobody would believe me. Like,
he just wouldn't leave her alone.
So that's when he fucking attacks her with a lie.
Once he knows, like,
oh, she's engaged,
there's no chance.
And he even said,
if I can't have her,
nobody will. And I'll make sure nobody even wants her if they could.
And sure enough,
he went through with that fucking threat.
Because abuse does not ever deescalate.
That shit gets worse and worse and worse and worse.
She does participate in the trial to get him arrested.
1857, when they first meet.
1959 is when she's attacked.
it's only fucking two years that this guy gets to this fucking point.
In 1961, that's when he was finally found guilty and sent to prison.
And she begins a new life.
The resilience and the strength
and the independence that this woman showed through this horrific
event
is amazing. She meets this dude,
he's like, I love you,
I wanna be with you,
I wanna meet, I wanna.
I want you to be my friend.
Like, I Wanna do this?
I wanna marry you.
Let's go. So she reveals her face,
her eyes to him.
This guy rejects her.
And I'm. That was just a little bit too much for her.
So she goes home and she's just like, uh.
So by 1971, she is living alone.
Her eyesight's worsening
and she's no longer the independent person she once was.
Homeboy Burt is still harassing her from jail. Because he's an attorney,
he is even starting lawsuits against her,
like, suing her for shit,
just to force her to respond.
So she's forced to interact with him for all these years.
Like, it never stops.
His harassment and abuse of her never fucking stops.
Even after the attack and after he's sent to prison.
So now she's finally like, it's.
It's worn her down.
She does not have anyone really loving or supporting her,
including her friends,
cause all of her friends are moving on. By 1973,
he reaches out to her,
she says something funny.
She says, show your good faith,
you know, send me some fucking money.
This is a man with the utmost need for power and control.
In two weeks, he sends her $4,000.
So this woman is blind, disabled.
All her friends are busy getting married and living their own lives.
Like not one of them gave a fuck to try to, like,
support her, be there for her.
No women empowering women. Back then, it was like,
bitch, I got mine.
And then it was just, peace out on you.
Like, I got my man,
you're stuck without yours.
So imagine somebody sends you a check for like,
you know, basically like 80% of what your annual salary is.
She's like, okay.
She hated him so much,
even after sending her that much money,
she wrote to the prison board and was like, look,
he fucking is still harassing me.
He sent me a check for $4,000.
Not only is he in there charge again,
but for policy making, fucking.
You know what I mean?
She tries to get him in so much trouble.
You know what the fucking Parole board does?
They're like, did you really fucking send her that money?
If we let you out,
would you continue sending her money?
He's like, yeah,
if I have it, sure.
I give her whatever I can.
They're like, okay.
They released him. September was when he sent her the check.
By March of 74,
he was paroled.
For 14 years in prison,
this man harassed this woman,
and then he's finally released her friends that were like,
I don't wanna help take care of her.
She needs a man.
They fucking arrange to have her meet him and give Bert another chance.
Like, well,
he proposed marriage, and like,
I bet, like, maybe something will happen, she gets back together with him.
She even said like,
well, I Know I love him,
I just don't like to use that word.
She's saying, I wanted him to fucking right.
You can see the anger and disdain for him as she talks about him
in those moments.
1996, he's accused of the same thing again.
A woman comes out and accuses him of the same thing.
And his fucking threats to her were real.
He's telling her,
you know what I did to my wife?
I'll do it to you.
And what does Linda do?
This is when I'm like,
okay, you're a stupid bitch.
And this is where you become complicit,
because she's literally defending him.
Knowing everything that.
I mean, she literally cannot see if she's defending him.
And she stayed with him until her dying day.
She died at 75 years old,
still married to him.
It's wild. She even says,
cause they show little clips of them and they're kind of bickering and.
And she just nitpicks at him and it just.
It does look a little bit miserable.
And she even says,
well, this is what he gets.
I feel like this is a little bit of his punishment.
This is a little bit of my revenge.
Like, I think this woman gave up on life and just decided like,
well, this is my only chance.
It's a wild, wild story, and I hope.
And when I look at the story,
my heart is really sad for that woman.
She just became everything she was.
Against.
And then she died